Alright so I'm going to come back to the
code, and this time I'm going to do something
new. Now because this class Child inherits from
class Parent this method show_info is also inherited. Now
this means that instances of class Child instances
like miley_cyrus, they can also call the show_info
method, even though this method is not explicitly
defined inside class Child. Let me do that next.
So the first thing I will do is uncomment
this line of code where I'm creating the instance
called miley_cyrus, and then use that instance, to call
the method show_info. There. Now because I want to focus
on the output of this show_info method, I'm going
to comment out the previous show_info method for now.
There. Now before I run this program, I want
to highlight one more time that I'm using the instance
miley_cyrus to call the method show_info. Now this
method does not explicitly exist inside class Child. But
because class Child inherits from class Parent this
method show_info is actually available to the instances of
class Child. So let me go ahead and save and run this program. And there is my
output. The program did not throw any errors, and
the last name and eye color of the instance
miley_cyrus did get printed out. Okay. So the next thing I am going to do is
create a method called show_info inside class Child,
and see what that does. So I'm going to create
a new method called show_info inside class Child.
Now this method show_info is going to print
out the three things associated with a child.
It's last name, eye color, and number of toys.
Here we are printing the last name of the
child. Now we are printing the child's eye color,
and finally, we are printing the number of toys.
In order to print this number correctly, we had to
wrap it around the string function. Now, if I
save and run this program, my hypothesis is that when
I call the show_info method using miley_cyrus, which by
the way is an instance of class Child. This show_info
method is going to get called and not the
show_info method in the class Parent. So let me
save and run this program. And there's the output.
We're printing out the last name, eye color and number
of toys of the instance of class Child. So
really what we have done here is defined the
method by the same name show_info inside class Child,
and also inside class Parent. This ability of a sub-class,
in this case the class Child, to override a method that
it inherited from its parent class is called Method Overriding in programming.